[Music]
it shouldn't come as a surprise to
anyone that the United States has the
largest military in the world by far as
of 2019
the US military budget accounted for
almost 40% of the entire world's
military spending with the u.s. spending
more money than the next ten nations
combined this data comes from a new
report by Cyprian find the full document
in the description below the report lays
out in detailed the accelerated military
spending of recent years including the
u.s. is massive jump from just under 700
billion dollars to 738 billion dollars
that increase alone is more than most
countries spend on their military budget
but the United States isn't alone
military spending has been on the rise
around the world as usual the u.s. is
leaps and bounds ahead of everyone else
but what's going on here
why is worldwide military spending
increasing and why does the u.s. spend
so much money on theirs as with most
questions to answer this one properly we
need to go back in time for a bit of
context after World War two the United
States was in a fairly strong position
to assume the title of the world's
greatest superpower
thanks to her geography the US had been
mostly isolated from the conflict abroad
we had done our part in bombing Japanese
cities into oblivion but our own
military and industrial hubs were left
intact
the war had devastated most of Europe
and this meant that these countries
needed to spend huge sums of money to
rebuild their shattered cities the
United States had no such problem the
resources we would have spent rebuilding
the nation could instead be pumped into
the military strengthening our nation's
already powerful forces this privileged
position of not having been nuked or
firebombed gave America the chance to
become a sort of world police force
defending our allies from aggressors
allowing them to spend their money on
infrastructure rather than their
militaries and deterring enemies from
attacking in the first place with the
rapid rebuilding of Russia and the
ascendancy of the Soviet Union
suddenly the US had a problem on its
hands a foreign entity bent on taking
America's spot as the dominant world
power the Cold War led to a rapid
escalation in military spending from
both powers and marked the greatest
spending until today the US and Soviet
Union both stocked up on nuclear weapons
and spy planes and poured huge sums of
money into beating each other in the new
arena of space flight eventually the
Soviet Union dissolved and tensions were
next military spending dropped as world
leaders realized that maybe nuclear war
is a bad idea then in 2001 the US was
whipped into a frenzy again with the
9/11 attacks popular support for
military action skyrocketed and we
kicked off a misguided war on terror
that were still fighting today at the
expense of billions of dollars and far
too many human lives from 2001 on with
very few exceptions the US military
budget has kept increasing every year
and that's where we get back to the
question why our perceived adversaries
in the Middle East don't have advanced
militaries so why do we keep upgrading
our equipment and buying new fighter
jets helicopters and submarines in a
word competition in recent years China
has exploded onto the world stage as a
capable economic and military power in
1990 China only accounted for 2% of the
world's military spending but by 2018 it
had jumped to 14% the second largest
behind the US that's a massive increase
and the US was spooked Chinese President
Xi Jinping has stated that he wants to
fully modernize China's army by the mid
2030s and take their place as a premier
world military power by the late 2040s
this goal includes building a military
presence that can rival the u.s. China
has already built two fully functional
aircraft carriers with another on the
way and invested in top-of-the-line
fighter jets and a significant cyber
warfare operation this last part is
crucial because the hyper modern US
military relies on information enabled
equipment and if China can find a way to
remove those advantages u.s. supremacy
goes out the window
combined the rapid rise of China with
the constant threat of old adversaries
like Russia and you can begin to see why
the u.s. feels the need to keep
increasing its military budget the
return of what's called great power
competition the kind we haven't seen
since World War two has been the spark
to ignite this latest wave of worldwide
military spending unfortunately this is
a self-reinforcing cycle that goes all
the way back to at least World War two
the great powers are embroiled in
conflict many are decimated in the
process the u.s. steps in to provide
military support for allies and
deterrence against enemies the USSR sees
the u.s. as an existential threat and
built up their own military the u.s.
sees this and gets spooked and increases
their own spending this goes back and
forth until the Soviet Union collapses
rinse and repeat with every new
perceived threat but that's not the only
problem America's hyper militarization
causes have
taking on the role of world police for
so long what happens when the u.s.
decides to pull out of a region it
leaves a power vacuum that threatens the
safety of the entire region because we
never gave those countries a chance to
build their own defenses other nations
that the u.s. is on less than friendly
terms with see what happens when the US
wants something and will feel the need
to build up their own defenses diplomacy
is used less and less often as we have
to justify our massive military budget
which convinces other nations that the
u.s. is a threat and prompts them to
buff their own militaries and the cycle
continues spending large sums of money
on a military is not necessarily a bad
thing
unless it's apps resources from other
critical projects like health care which
the US does but that's a topic for
another video the real problem with this
worldwide increased spending is that it
indicates we have entered another era of
violent competition between world powers
when nations build new bombers and
nuclear submarines it's because they
intend to have them as an option when
the time comes you can say all
militaries are strictly for deterrence
but look around the US has been fighting
a pointless war for almost 20 years long
after it's become apparent that the
conflict began under false pretenses
we've dropped atomic bombs on densely
populated cities fire bombed plenty of
others and have come literally one
decision from global nuclear war in the
past if war between great powers breaks
out or even between lesser powers with
nuclear weapons that's it the gloves
come off and the massive militaries the
world has built over the last two
decades will be used to their fullest
potential the u.s. is not alone in its
dangerous acceleration of military
spending but as the world's sole
superpower setting an example of
non-violence could go a long way towards
ensuring a peaceful future what do you
think is the u.s. justified in spending
almost seven hundred forty billion
dollars on weapons of war or should the
country adjust its priorities let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
and if you'd like to learn more about
the conflict that launched America to
its place as the world's largest
superpower I highly recommend you check
out Apocalypse World War two on
curiosity stream it's a fascinating look
at the deadliest war in human history
and how it changed the world if you
watch my videos you'll know I'm a big
fan of curiosity stream it's an online
streaming service with thousands of
nonfiction titles from some of the best
filmmakers in the game you can find tons
of great episodes like the apocalypse
series and they've got a bunch of
material on technology in outer space
which are some of my favorites they're
giant catalogue includes content on
science nature astronomy technology and
style among others unlimited access
starts at just $2.99 a month and as a
special offer just for you guys you can
get a free trial by following the link
below
curiosity stream is available on just
about every platform you can imagine so
wherever you are you'll always have
access to great interesting content as
an added bonus
your curiosity stream subscription now
comes with a free Nebula subscription
nebula is a new streaming platform built
by and for creators like Wendover
productions real engineering Kurtz cos
Act
and of course second thought and many
others it's a place for us to try new
things and make original content that
just wouldn't be possible on YouTube
help support the brands that support me
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you visit
curiosity stream comm slash second
thought if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more like it consider
subscribing to stay up to date with my
latest episodes if you hated it go ahead
and drop a thumbs down and if you really
want to help support my channel I
recently started a patreon which you can
find at patreon.com slash second thought
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week